one big development that came in the
middle of that hearing was the Supreme
Court rejecting an appeal from the
former president in another high-profile
case Trump had asked the court to
intervene in the fight over the FBI's
search of his Mar-A-Lago estate a move
that would have allowed the special
Master to see documents Mark classified
that were taken in the search senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge is at the justice department
for us this morning Catherine good
morning
Tony good morning the Supreme Court
decision is a defeat for the Trump legal
team the order means judge Raymond deary
Who was appointed by a Florida federal
judge will continue his independent
review of the more than 11 000 documents
seized by the FBI but will not review
those 103 documents with classified
markings Trump's legal team continued to
raise questions about the classification
status of the documents his lawyers also
argued Trump as president had absolute
authority to declassify records the
justice department successfully argued
the claims were without Merit because
the relevant records belonged to the
government the criminal investigation
and a National Security review of those
sensitive records will continue Nate
Catherine thank you